if you're in the back it's a rap you're
both in the back and they're knocking on
the front window i'll arrest me now
arrest me now cause i'm i promise you
now if i'm in the back you're naked i'm
naked and i'm not opening any windows
i will hide down like that
if he's knocking if he's steaming he
can't see [ __ ] and he's knocking he can
keep knocking
guys
ladies
um
what's going on man
what is actually going on uh me and
foreign talking we've just realized that
episode 100 is actually around the
corner it is around the corner episode
100 is creeping up so if you've got any
fun ideas for us let us know
um don't say dumb [ __ ]
don't say just dumb stuff of course they
will bro
i'll tell you what i said inspired
yesterday like
some of the would you rather's that you
man put in sometimes just to get a feel
for where we're at i love to just ask
what's going on yeah
the guy i'm gonna stick this on the guys
because the girls come better
girls typically come more correct yeah
the guys
anything gay they can put in there
they'll just do it
because i don't know bro it's just like
so unimaginative yeah do you know what i
mean
i don't mind a jokey
humorous
homoerotic
kind of would you rather but some of it
is just laziness
i agree some of it's just laziness like
would you rather wrestle a shark and
it's in its home to rain with nothing
but coral to save your life
or just
[ __ ] suck off a stranger
are you like what
what are you talking about
yeah
it's so annoying yeah it's be more
original yeah
yeah yeah like would you rather fight
all might on its best day or suck
through that off you're like
what are you on about you had me up fast
and then uh you're just worried lazy
lazy
would you rather fight all my audi's
best day
to be fair
i would rather suck you off to fight all
mine obviously but still lazy question
[Laughter]
um bam speaking of all might yeah i know
you haven't seen it yet demon slayer
movie bro mugen train i know i need to
watch it i need to watch it the thing i
want to watch um like uh what's the word
i'm looking for like a recap of season
one because i did that for i don't know
if you spoke about if i spoke about this
one here but i did that for season one
to three of attack on time before i
started season four okay five minute
recapting fair play on youtube i would
say actually to be fair with the movie
even though the movie is directly
related to the thing yeah you don't need
to recap oh really you don't it's a
completely
separate situation as long as you
remember who the characters are yeah
they don't bring back any
knowledge that they've learned
previously okay to utilizing this okay
not really okay there's a few references
here and there that you'll be fine with
but like
yeah you don't need a recap you said you
saw it in the cinema as well right oh
yeah yeah oh yeah bro
bro the movie's amazing dang
how long is it uh like two hours
the movie's amazing bro
i can't wait amazing i nearly cried
twice really
damn these man damn they don't play bro
did you not know it's in my background
my man i saw that i saw that yeah arms
bro
because we've not seen him properly do
anything we've not seen him properly
yeah anything
arms bro
arms these hashida man yeah they're on a
different level i feel like even though
you said i shouldn't i don't need to
watch your recap i need to i feel like i
need if you want to i've been a minute
for me it's fine dude do what you need
to do bro
the
your face the movie's wild bro
i'm i'm here for it i didn't expect it
anything less from it to be fair i
didn't expect anything less for me it's
so live um i am definitely looking
forward to it definitely it's like they
did a thing where it's just like it's
almost like two movies in one okay where
they've done a thing where they set up
this whole thing for the whole movie and
this is the premise of the movie
and then they just
like at like the last half an hour it's
just like oh let's do this as well just
just fit it in it still fits but it's
just like let's do this as well does it
do you think that bit you're just
talking about now that last half an hour
do you think that rolls into season
two uh yes it kind of does um
but yeah it's just
you wanna you wanna speak you can't say
too much speak about
the tip
bro
yeah obviously clearly guys i've not
seen the movie yet so that's why he's
not it's not going on about it so
amazing
it makes me also want to be a better man
it actually makes me want to be a better
human being overall okay you just it's
one of those things where you watch it
there's a couple like naruto ones like
that but it reminds me of like uh you
know you see rockley and he's training
bro and he's like if i can't do 100
press-ups i've got to do 200 squats yeah
it's just like he wants to be the best
person he can be yeah in all like facets
and like that's like my man uh what's
his name ringoku i think his name is bro
he's so he's up here at all times
no matter what's going on bro he's
he's calm collected and just like
protective of everyone all the time at
all times bro no matter what's going on
he holds his morals so high okay no
matter what's going on i might watch it
today you're guessing me i'm gonna bro
you have to watch it today you don't
need a recap i'm gonna watch it it's
amazing bro
you have to watch it all right say no
more he's up here fam okay he makes me
want to be a better man damn he actually
makes me want to do better bro all right
but i'm going to watch it yeah i'm going
to use him he is the fire behind
my
titanium
yeah okay okay okay
on another level bro okay on another
level
yeah it's um it's unbelievable they're
so good for it it is so good i'm here
for it um but yeah
definitely yeah definitely jump on that
that's so sick ah
wow
again
um because it's all like it's online as
well and it's clear as well crystal
clear online i haven't even checked it
online but i'm assuming that this point
definitely is crystal clear online oh
okay but i know because there was people
i see people on tik tok doing um
always there's always links on tik tok
for the last few months there's always
been links on tick tock like oh you can
watch them say i'm over here and then i
would like oh gang and then i'll click
it because i never knew it was going to
come to the uk cinemas yeah so far
yeah bro i'm gonna have to watch it
online and then every time i click it it
was trash quality i'm just i'm not
willing to do it bro
um
so yeah when i saw it was available on
cinema it was only available for two
days and cinema near me wednesday
thursday thing so i said bang we're
there um oh
okay oh it was wild
yeah but i was like wild
he was just staring at me wild bro
um i'm here for it but yeah that was
sick um anyway guys well go on
welcome patreon
you know youtube like subscribe share
the thing
jump on the instagram jump on the
twitter jump in the comments bro jump in
my dm's we're everywhere wherever
whatever
we're available active yeah we're here
we're about um
obviously guys hit us up with am i the
asshole's
fan request hit me up with some one's
got a ghost as well guys one's gotta go
yeah man some fun facts yeah man we love
it we love it
it's all good um
but yeah speaking of fun facts my g
what are you saying
uh this week um fun fact
an australian man bill morgan was once
declared dead but came back round after
fourteen minutes
to celebrate he bought a scratch card
and won twenty seven thousand at one a
twenty seven thousand dollar car
days later the news asked him to
reignite the moment so he bought another
ticket he won again but this time he won
250 thousand dollars that's impossible
bro
i'm gonna read the full thing
so the real story behind um the viral
video everyone's talking about an aussie
legend who won 250k scratch jackpot on
camera after waking up from a 15-day
coma reveals what happens next and it's
not all good
oh wow okay
so bill morgan's life has been full of
luck good and bad he should have died in
june 1998 and for eight and for 14
minutes he did but somehow doctors
managed to revive him after he had a
heart attack and spent 15 days in a coma
mr morgan then 37 was living in a
caravan in melbourne and was dubbed a
medicine a medical miracle sorry his
second lucky break came when he bought
an instant scratch card about a year
later and promptly won a brand new
toyota corolla worth 30k in dollars
the winfor attracted a lot of media
attention
and that's when it happened again his
claim to viral fame re-emerged uh some
22-year 22 years later on everyone's
facebook feed
um the feedback the footage sorry
captures mr morgan buying another
scratch card to he reenact the moment
only to win the jackpot he was like i
just won 250 dollars 250 000 sorry i'm
not joking he says to the camera in
disbelief i think i'm gonna have another
heart attack and this is his face
this is his face
that
i need to see that video that's wild
that is wild no i'm gonna see if there's
an actual video of it
because i think there is but
sometimes when i um i go to watch full
video oh yeah
and even more good luck when we asked
bill to reenact buying his scratchy
ticket
i just won 250 000
i'm
so
first of all how
boring is wherever they live in
australia that years after he won this
car they're doing a reenactment
a car
a toyota corolla
well it was in 1998.
facebook wasn't a was facebook about
back then nah i mean it wasn't but like
still the news
are doing a a story on my man for
winning a car on a scratch card
there must be nothing going on where
they live right 1998 i feel like there
wasn't that much happening in the world
they're probably there there probably
was but there probably wasn't as much
like
because there was no social media none
of that yeah they were just recording
anything yeah you know yeah yeah so
that's crazy to imagine they were like
cool like we're just gonna do like a
quick quick story on you when your
toyota et cetera et cetera um so what
we're going to do is we're going to be
narrating it um and we're just going to
have some video footage so if you could
just buy a quick scratch card now and
then we'll record you scratching it and
then obviously we'll talk about you in
the car and all this stuff and they'd be
like yeah cool cool cool man was
actually scratching this one i just won
250k you see him scratch and you see his
stop
like
you see his hand just he's perplexed cuz
i just won 250 kai and he's like
i'm not [ __ ] joking
i'm gonna cry
i'm gonna [ __ ] cry i couldn't win
that money i couldn't i would tell you
now bro
oh my god i fall to my knees i would
fall down i'd be able to breathe
i'd need i'm not sleeping until that
money's in my account yeah there's no
pending yeah i'm holding on to that
piece of paper i'm holding this fragile
take me to wherever i need to go now and
now bro did you know with the lottery
and stuff yeah obviously if you don't do
it online if you actually do like a
scratch card yeah yeah for example bro
it's sasena what do you mean
it's dangerous bro it's like
did you know that's basically it if you
win this if you if you get the scratch
card
i'm pretty sure if you read the back of
the scratch card it says like if you win
the big big bucks yeah they can't give
you you need to go to a spot you have to
go to a spot or if you can't get there
you have to put it in the post yeah i'm
not putting it in the post bro yeah yeah
yeah i've read it yeah are you crazy
i'm not putting it in the box i'm
driving to wherever i need to go yeah
tell me where i need to be at i'm not
putting it in the post because postman
donnie already knows this address he's
familiar with this address oh one
million if i'm a postman i'm familiar
with that actually if i'm a postman and
i see that address bro
sue me bang sue me fire me wherever you
i don't care my it's my money now
i'm swiping that open yeah yeah yeah
that's not a game man i'm familiar it's
not a game bro
that i'm
these these posties bro they do what
they want they do what they want yeah my
boy when i was in school his dad was a
postman and he told me he used to
achieve things
every single day um oh yeah oh hit me up
with some stories um if you remember
anything uh he teased a couple phones
uh some games no he'd always be able to
tell when there's a card like a birthday
card with money in it so just open it
take the money out seal it back up no
send them the card
yeah bro postman don't care
about this was when i was a kid yeah
obviously this is just like 20 years ago
probably like 20 years ago of course
know um but yeah
i'm sure they've tightened it up now i
sincerely hope so but yeah
from then i've never put anything
valuable in the post [ __ ] never bro
even when i used to do like um
we buy any phone or whatever and i'd
sell my old phone on there when they
tell me to put it in the post i used to
be vexed
so i figured this got it goes like
that's the that's my money yeah that's
everything yeah yeah yeah yeah and
that's when i was at uni as well i was
like i did that all the time i did that
recycle thing all the time oh bro
yeah quick hundred pounds i needed that
yeah the same you felt like the bell of
the ball when you got right
these times they give you p for it now
you know
they give you people i was gonna do it
for my my old phone but the one before
this one so what did i have before this
what's this 11 11 i think i had the 10
okay
i think they were going to give they
were gonna run me like three four
hundred pound for it oh really can swell
down so what do you do did you do it i
saw it to someone else oh okay okay for
like um
why
boy
okay fair enough yeah yeah yeah fair
enough enough um mates racing that
mm-hmm um
but yeah i hate putting valuable [ __ ] in
the most i hate because i just assume
it's gone
i just assume obviously nowadays
i'm assuming obviously because of what
your friends pops told you back then it
makes sense but there's so much
more nowadays in terms of like tracking
blah blah blah
oh yeah bro it's a rare well
i've never experienced anything going
missing from my [ __ ] that i've ordered
or something something i'm expecting
yeah i mean the only thing for me is
like amazon stuff and they'll just send
it to you again yeah true they can
afford that though yeah but like um like
uh you know lewis
he was doing like pokemon cards on ebay
and stuff that's sick he was yeah he was
just breaking he was making a bit of pee
actually yeah but um
he was doing pokemon cards on there and
like any time i see a decent like a
crazy deal like because a lot of people
don't know what their cards are worth
yeah yeah so he'd be buying stuff on
ebay and it could be like a card that's
worth like five grand but they're
selling it for like 50 quid because they
just don't know so he'd be trying to buy
that and you buy that and bro he's for
the until it comes he's pulling his hair
out yeah he's pulling his hair out bro
thinking please come like please don't
get lost in the post please don't let
this person change their mind everything
just please run me this card i need this
card yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i need
this [ __ ]
pokemon cards i remember used to collect
i at least have a booklet where you had
all the slots in
yeah yeah i buried them i can't remember
now i had so many of them in primary
school probably didn't roll i don't
think it rolled over to secondary school
maybe it did but uh
what they're probably worth now would be
ridiculous because that's at least 20
years surely oh yeah bro people make
pee on pokemon cards right now
i didn't keep any of that i didn't keep
us i had a shiny i did for a while but
obviously now yeah bro like i had like
a shiny um
blastoise first edition shiny blastoise
i had i traded it for certain stupid
like some sweets or some [ __ ]
right now that's worth money money cake
yeah let me actually google it yeah i'm
going to go on like google yeah um
first edition shiny blastoise
what i like worth or something like that
shiny blast toys
how much is the first edition first
how much
how much is it worth
a 99 pokemon game two blasters holo
first edition card mint condition most
recent price
five point eight thousand dollars
and an smr price which i don't know what
that means
uh nine thousand dollars
yeah oh dear yeah i sold that for pika
mix bro yeah
someone on ebay is selling
a charizard base set first edition
shadowless i don't know there's so many
thingies for nearly a quarter of a
million pounds bro these these things
are no game bro a quarter
of a million
pounds
yeah pokemon's not a joke
what
a man is charging 70 dollars for pmp
postage and packaging as well
he's not gonna be able to sell that he's
not he's never selling it
he's not then again you never know you
never know but he's not gonna understand
no
um
[ __ ] but yeah bro i had cards i had
cards but i don't remember the cards i
don't remember what cards i had i just
remember that one because i remember
specific i even remember where i was
sitting in primary school yeah because i
remember the same day my boy
his name's rafiq
told me um
about he was muslim and he was fasting
and that's the first day i learned about
what ramadan was anything and i remember
thinking this is the most crazy [ __ ]
i've ever heard bro what are you talking
about i get it yeah um
yeah
his name's not rafiq is sadiq that's
what his name was rafiq i don't even
know sadiq his name was siddique and mum
was like yeah yeah i think i was eating
like a jam sandwich or some [ __ ] and i
was like oh do you want something
because it was lunchtime he went eating
and he was like nah nah nah i'm fasting
and i was like yo what and i said oh i'm
not allowed to eat from like when the
sun's up and i was like why
and he was like oh like it's ramadan and
i was like big man what are you
you i keep asking you a question you're
not answering it
[Laughter]
every time i ask you why you keep giving
me a stupid answer what are you on about
do you want food or not
or not bro
um
and yeah he was like oh nice i'm fasting
it's ramadan and i was like what are you
on about yeah it's ramadan bro when is
ramadan you're not allowed to eat and he
couldn't even explain it properly yeah
but yeah it's like it's my religion when
it's ramadan you're not allowed to eat
from when it sounds like you can only
eat when the sun's down and i was like
so you haven't eaten today he was like
no i'm not gonna eat until like late
late and i was like nah bro i'm hungry
while i'm eating you must be starving
starving and i remember sitting in a
bench on the playground yeah and i
remember thinking [ __ ] that and then i
saw my other boy
uh playing pokemon cards and they were
actually having like an actual like
battle or whatever
and i went and chilled over
and then i had like some cards in my
pocket and i was like oh you messed up
yeah thunderbolt yeah mad
and then when i had like donnie like p
had a picky mix yeah bare cherry coke
bottles in there bro and i was like i
want that i want that i don't know who
was saying what did you like make a
video what you got you got for me you're
not having nothing and i was like come
on man run that yeah and he said all
right cool um and he was playing his
pokemon cards and he was like oh have
you got that um shiny blastoff because
he asked me to bring in just so we could
see it he's like you've got that shiny
blastoise and i was like yeah i got that
of course i showed it in music cool you
can have all of them if you give me this
and i was like
bet
easy money
dumbass
easy money as soon as you did the
exchange he must have fought you
absolutely tall
oh absolutely you don't even know where
oh i was just sucking that fizzy cherry
cola like one
this is life
such a kid such a kid's mistake bro
these times that's worth grants grand
now and i'm here broke grand bro yeah
[ __ ] yeah i'll tell all of that now i
would oh for sure fingers as well my mom
keeps everything if i had that book to
keep it in mint condition and stuff like
that if i would have just had it as a
kid my mom would have kept it in a
filing cabinet if i just asked her to
like she would have kept it and it would
still be pristine until now
it would have been i could have cracked
that open and just be like
and then just bang
shiny i had cards i had a shiny pikachu
had a shiny blast toys i remember those
two i'm certain i had a charizard i had
i'm pretty sure i had a shiny charizard
i had a zapdos
yeah
i had we had a zapdos
i just let that one go yeah
really
i didn't have any legendary birds
i had a um
[Music]
i remember had a
uh what was it
uh what was the so it's
machamp that's what i had okay a shiny
machamp yeah yeah yeah um
and i feel like my hitmon
lee which one's the kicking one
hitmonlee yeah
my hitmonlee was shiny i feel like it
was i don't know why it would be but i
feel like my hitmonlee was showing me
too i didn't even know but
yeah bro
[ __ ] those were the days yeah bro i got
this one football cards as well yeah i
had yu-gi-oh cards too i don't think i
had hugo cards me and my brother were so
into yugioh bro we were so into yugioh
that we you would um
we would print off
uh because we couldn't we had no money
um and my dad or my mom wouldn't buy us
yugioh cards for eventually my dad
brought us some but like
my dad wasn't the one to like even
though he's weird like
my dad wasn't like
oh let's just go toy store or something
like that if we're like okay we want
this or whatever he'd never be like all
right get shoes on let's go toy shop and
get some
he would be like if we
if we needed something um
and or if it was a birthday so my dad's
like birthdays and christmas would spoil
you yeah yeah or if you need saturn for
like school or something he'd you could
ask for anything and you'd get it so if
i needed i remember i need i wanted i
was doing athletics i had all these
athletics tournaments and i wanted to
buy spikes
um
the running shoes and i was like oh i
want to buy some spikes where can i get
them and then he was like yeah yeah so
we went to shop to get some and they
were like a hundred pound and i was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah like he's never
gonna let him i thought they were gonna
be like a tenant bro i'm not gonna lie
to you they're so flimsy i thought they
were gonna be like a ten hour yeah so i
was like [ __ ] i know i just thought what
wasted trip and i was like oh this is
the only one they have you know you
looked it was oh okay he didn't say
nothing just bought him was like
you were looking around he did not look
at the price
man one
yeah bro so i remember that's the kind
of that my dad was but if we would we
could talk about yugioh cast till the
sun comes home yeah we ain't getting it
until it's someone's birthday i mean
that's not saying get your shoes on
let's go toy shop no it's not happening
yeah fair enough um i like that though
yeah it was good yeah it was good so
um
what we used to have to do was go on
microsoft word
get all the images of the cards put on a
word document print it off and cut it
out
we'd be playing
you gear cards with the same thing and
would stick it together with glue so
it's like the same when you decide to
give it a little bit of thickness so
we'd have to yeah no yeah it would be
one side of the image was the back of
the card and one side was the front and
then we'd glue it together and then we'd
be playing but obviously we would only
print off the most ridiculous cards bro
we had [ __ ] um
blue eyes white dragon blue eyes like
dragon dark magician red eyes black
dragon
the flipping um
what uh what's what's my man's name the
uh
this is five pieces you get his arm his
leg his face i know he's i can't
remember but i know oh wait i can't
remember that
bro for the life of me i'm never gonna
remember um
exodia
exodia was his name yeah yeah we both
had exodia so we would just be playing
with ridiculous cards bro yeah it was
stupid it was actually stupid um but it
was fun though if you think back now you
could have probably laminated and and
falsified them as cards
oh no the print quality was terrible oh
is it it was terrible
i'm thinking about printers nowadays
yeah yeah
[Music]
one page back in the day would take like
10 minutes oh my days especially if it's
a picture
you would i would draw every line i
wouldn't dare waste waste color ink i
used to sam okay
so back her day right primary school
times i used to have the same way we
used to have um
folders and folders of pokemon cards we
used to have folders and folders and
folders of dragon ball z characters all
right all printed all color i used to
waste ink
i don't know why i used to have them
because it's not like they weren't
dragon ball z cars and i used to have
them because i always wanted to draw
them in school i used to draw them i
used to draw them all the time at school
and i always want the best fusions
i draw this android so i just wanted to
be that guy i don't know why yeah yeah
bro i used to waste ink yes obviously
color ink is way more expensive though
oh yeah bro my parents always used to go
off at me
off is that why what are you doing
printing this [ __ ] what are you doing
i'm just oh look i'm sick this is what i
do
i used to take it to school and just get
another piece of paper and just trace on
it just trace it and be like gang this
is me yeah
i've just done one i've just done one
vegeta
i've just done one vegetating and this
is me bro i don't remember
the same oh it's a trace she's the trace
i used to do simpsons characters and i
used to trace it and show my stepdad
like where is it
look at that amazing you just traced
that and i'm like so that's what i'm
doing this is art because you're a hater
you're a hater i had booklets of dragon
ball z bro
that's so funny i loved it
wow i loved it that is so
funny bro wasted i wasted ink and money
on that bro
inc and my ink used to be done all the
time man i know you should be like mom
man there's no ink there's never a
[ __ ] link in the sprinkler why do we
even have one
yeah it's a print ship for joke oh
that's too
that's so funny it's so funny about the
dragon ball z characters i wanted to be
that guy as well oh i wanted to be the
guy that's sick of drawing anime
characters
back then yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's the link now anyway but oh
yeah
wow bro that's all i did that's what i
did my spare time um i loved it
this is way this is way
past this happened ages ago okay but i
want to speak to you about it and i also
can't forget to speak to you about
how mad is obviously completely
different topic yeah how mad is it about
that um
that racist yeah in worcester
that just got deleted
the one with the which was going on with
the doorman yeah the one that you went
viral yeah yeah yeah yeah
but social media social media justice
these days will just end you yeah of
course of course i'm surprised people
don't take heed into that and they're
like you know what i mean she called him
every name under every name under the
spot on the floor everything bro every
name understand she tried to apologize
the next day or whatever is it was that
actually her because megaman are saying
oh it was fake accounts i don't know i
didn't search the account to find out
where they were so basically she made
this like statement like oh i'm sorry
and like she she tried to use the
freedom of speech card in it and i spoke
to a few men and they were like oh i
think it's like a fake account because
apparently
at that time loads of fake apologies and
stuff came out some of them were more
outrageous than others all under the
same name okay so no one knows if it was
actually her account it seemed like it
possibly could be because it was like
quite sincere yeah and it was about like
oh i left my id in my car i didn't have
to walk on my very specific to the
situation specifically yeah like a you'd
have to be a bit of a sociopath if you
just made that up yeah yeah yeah yeah um
but yeah
it was mad to me
that in the space of 24 hours i remember
seeing it on someone's page because it
happened in in worcester
um
or did it happen in birmingham i can't
remember i think she's from worcester i
don't know if it happened in birmingham
i think i've been in brum yeah happened
to be happening yeah yeah uh oh yeah she
works for bosh in worcester that's it
okay she got sacked i'm not surprised
bro
in the space of 24 hours
the video comes out
and then i saw it on someone's story who
actually lives in in birmingham so i was
like okay cool happened to birmingham
then
um and the one the repost i saw it from
was actually from
the bouncers page
so he'd put it on his story it was like
i'll be balancing not his story he put
it on his um instagram and was like oh
i've been working as a doorman for this
amount of time
i've seen a lot of [ __ ] but this is like
ridiculous
um
and so i saw that and someone reposted
it who actually follows him anyway and
is their friend and stuff
and that was the first one i saw and
you're like oh man that's what a [ __ ]
and then
bro within the space of an hour it was
on people's stories that's
that have no nothing to do with each
other i'm seeing it all over the place
yeah and as soon as i saw it i think i
saw it on um
i can't remember maybe one girl that we
went to uni with or something and she i
think she lives in like essex and i saw
it in hers like five minutes after i saw
her mama's and she has no relation to
the person i saw in there as soon as i
saw it on that i was like oh this girl's
done yeah this girl was done at it and
then i saw on another one and another
one another one i was like it's rap
don't know it's a wrap and then i saw
people posting like let's find her who
she is and suffer for oh
people talk about she works for this
like her this is her name she works for
like bosch or something next thing you
know bosch is sending out a tweet saying
we don't know who this is but if she
does work for us then he doesn't
anymore
and i was like wow less than 24 hours my
girl's jobless done
i mean serves you right i've got no pity
towards her oh it serves you 100 i have
no peter but it just astounds me it's
like
wow bro if you get caught on camera
doing that it's a wrap for you there's
no
there's no judge jewelry yeah there's
it's it's it's a wrap for you bro
people don't learn that's just it people
are stupid man people are stupid they do
stupid things
and they
the worst part is
what the aftermath like the apology and
the
well it's just that don't even bother
don't even bother my girl said she said
freedom
bro on the video she said everything
with her chest oh she said everything
was yeah she said she
that's normal for her oh it's
recreational first yeah that's normal
for her the apology is just like
it's not really i would i would have
respected i don't respect your anywhere
but i would have been like
if she didn't apologize okay i [ __ ] up
i accept it boom i would have respected
that a lot more
really yeah i would have said to her
more if she was like i'm racist and what
i would respect for the most if she said
that i i wouldn't expect her to say that
you know i mean yeah i won't expect
anyone to see that so that's why i said
i'll respect it a lot more yeah okay i'm
[ __ ] up i take on the chin boom i'm
cancelled
run this whole apology thing they'll
probably from when she said i've got
black co-workers not even friends i've
got black co-workers and i've even dated
black men in the past i'm thinking oh
babes oh you're just digging up
yeah
one of our boys said sutton that was so
funny yeah
that had me crying the other day yeah he
was talking about that thing yeah that
man said um
he said i wish she didn't say about the
dated black men because the sisters are
gonna hold on to that boy
i was like bro
black women are going to hold on to that
forever now
they're like is this what humanity into
it always falls back to the moment
oh wow oh black men this is what we're
into you know swear down
mad that's annoying that joke's quite
annoying
why is it now our problem
man said the sisters are gonna grips
that
that's so true
oh it's annoying but it's so true god
hilarious breaking out hilarious
i was howling i felt for [ __ ] sake
they've let us daddy yeah yeah yeah i've
let the squad down again oh flipping
hell yeah she's done at it
she's done for bro oh my daisy she is
this is
like i said no sympathy man no she is
she deserves to be cancelled and
she just needs to
well for future reference other people
need to just take that and be like okay
cool
i just can't say anything do anything i
just need to be a normal human being you
know yeah bro you literally just need to
be a little normal
and just watch what you say in mind
where you step and that's it and look
after yourself car the world the streets
won't look after you yeah bro
if that thing was real she said like ah
ah but you man like i understand what i
did was wrong but i've lost my job like
livelihood no livelihood do you not know
how that's affecting me is i think my
that's
that's the dice you rolled bro whole
issue now
up in town calling my monkey this and
n-word that's spitting on the floor
what do you expect brother
babes babes a lot of people see that's
that's why i don't sympathize with
people like her because
that's why i said this apology thing is
so it's so facetious because
you know what you were saying when you
were saying
i don't care if you were drunk i don't
care where your idea was you know all
these things and it's only because if
she never got fired if she never
if her company stuck behind her if all
these things happened that benefited her
she wouldn't have apologized she would
have gone with her day she wouldn't she
wouldn't they would she would have felt
no need to say oh i've got black
co-workers this oh you are taking my
life with that
she would have just cracked on she would
have just and it's just like your
apology's facetious doesn't mean
anything to us yeah it's pointless bro
you've rolled your dice you've got to
deal with the consequences yeah yeah you
have to deal with the consequences you
haven't got any co-workers gee it's done
you're done out here for a minute you
have to move
i hate that you have to like co-workers
what is that
what even is that just take your l and
move bro
yeah i know you mean if you just said
bro
the game is the game if she would if she
would have just tweeted you know what
the game is a game and i'm gonna hold
this l
i said what i said well you heard me say
it doesn't matter
what does it matter if i'm racist or not
yeah it actually doesn't matter matter i
understand this game is the game
understand the implications now the
implications are
yeah it's tough out here it's tough it's
hard out here for a pimp
so we win some we lose some
he imagined that was an ending speech
that was close i would give her a round
of applause i'd be like okay fair enough
you you you handed it unexpectedly i
rate anyone who's willing to hold any
airwolf chest
i hear that and just be like [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up i hear that i don't agree with
you but you [ __ ] up yeah
or a woman and um i'm reaping
the punishment for it boy and tis what
is what do you want me to say the game
is the game the game is the game is the
game thing is if she didn't say anything
then everyone would be like
i should not even say anything
you can't win in those situations yeah
yeah she can't win yeah um you said you
had a situation in it yeah so i just
want to read through you now okay so
boom
um scenario so when i live with my dad's
uh my boyfriend and i used to go out and
get up to stuff in his car
we once parked in a quiet car we once
parked in a quiet corner of a pub car
park down the road and started kissing
which led to steamy foreplay binder the
windows is steamed up and we and we
quickly got carried away with what we
were doing and when 10 minutes later we
heard a knock on our window
absolutely mortified we got ourselves
half respectful and rolled down the
window
to an un to an annoyed patron
unbeknownst to us my boyfriend hadn't
put the handbrake on and we had rolled
into the middle of the car park blocking
all of the cars from leave and said the
queue was three four cars long
and he had
three four of them
waiting to leave with their partners and
families who had been sat in their car
rocking and starting staring at the
rocking condensed car
what would you do if you were the guy
what do you do if you're the guy in the
car bro the boyfriend
so you're in a whip yeah you've rolled
up to your girl's yard right yeah yeah
sweet one you guys have been for you've
been frothing for days now but you've
not had a chance to smash because
obviously she lives with the pups so she
you um your mrs is like oh dad i'm
taking your car out for a spin we're
just gonna go to little cinema obviously
you bop out now you're there your lips
and lips and lips and you're doing your
things our babes
let me let's let's do a little tingling
let's do that thing yeah man the bed is
rocking the car's rocking now it's
steamy
you don't feel nothing you'll get you're
in it you're engulfed in the music's
playing and it's dark it's like 9pm
music's music's playing it's dark
rocking
on the window you're startled cuz
absolutely startled quickly again put
the boxes on put a tee on roll down the
window
all right what's up you're welcome
you're welcome um
wag one is that you're blocking the road
i can see your car rocking and it's
three on four of the cars
we're all trying to get out we're all
trying to get out we're tired it's late
it's late so wrap this up
so we can leave
fam
big
mortified i would literally just have to
say my bad and speed skirt out
that's all you [ __ ] hazards on you know
you do the quick
sorry bad
bad
bad ah it's peak it's the windscreen
steamy and you have to air on it and you
have to wait
or just
what it was
mortified
mortified one of them ones where you're
both on the same chair as well or you're
both in the same seat because she's
climbed over or you climbed over
or you're both in the back if you're in
the back it's a rap you're both in the
back and they're knocking on the front
window i'll rest me now arrest me now
because i'm i promise you now if i'm in
the back you're naked i'm naked and i'm
not opening any windows
i will hide down like that if he's
knocking if steaming if he can't see
[ __ ] and he's knocking he can keep
knocking
i'm not here
okay bet imagine you're in a back seat
yet he keeps knocking and no one's
answering oh yeah i bet
he you you um he you wait for about a
minute and he stopped knocking right
and you stop so you always start feeling
madden push in the car there's two or
three men then pushing the car now what
do you do you're just in there like
what's going on
what's going on
i'll be posted up
just
i don't know what i'll do
i don't know what i do dick's swinging
nah i don't know what i do i'll panic
i
actually don't know fam neither do i
i would be in such a state
your girl be crying she'll be in
hysterics she'll be so embarrassed for
her
yeah you'll go be crying bro she'll be
hysteric she wouldn't want anyone to see
her
welcome
now i'm just thinking oh okay i thought
something happened
wow
it's just like a pitch black car park
three four cars deep
you've ignored them knocking so two of
them come out start rocking your car
now bro no no no no no i'll tell you
that i'm not buying it
why not
yeah that's not banging at all probably
that's not hanging
i don't know what i'd do i don't know
how i'd escape i don't know what
what would happen
i'm not opening the door they can push
me to where i need to be pushed to yeah
and then just hope it stops i hope
everything stops
what a nightmare is that real that's
real yeah
nah han you demanded of the handbrake on
rookie mistake
how you not felt that
they were gonna be they would go there
ocean and emotionally yoshi they thought
steamy car sex bangs
bangs so uncomfortable
very very very uncomfortable
but when it's in oh
yeah yeah yeah
even if you can only move like
it's not it's going for it
it's wild
it really is wild i haven't banged in a
car since i was a teenager i haven't
banged on a car in four or five years
yeah i've done it since probably like 11
years
i've done it since i was young
in the in the clio in the clio yeah that
must have been uncomfortable i was awful
bro awful i remember doing it one time
it was daylight outside
daylight so after a night out summer
night out me and my my girlfriend i was
up with my girlfriend at the time
just pulled up on one um like tesco
express car park
went for it bro but it was light so i'm
out here
praying the whole time
i was on top yeah and bro it'll be two
pumps and and check
and i'm pretty sure i could see one don
walking but like you know when you're in
it and you just have to keep moving even
when you just
you just have to just slow slowly down
just thrust the hit slow just rock the
pelvis because she at this moment she
doesn't care
[ __ ] me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah women are the worst
women are the worst ones in the motion
they don't get
well
why is jacob try to ring me
don't mind i'll ring it back in a minute
all right cool so am i there so i am
so me and my girlfriend were chat
so me and my girlfriend were chatting we
tell each other everything so she told
me that there was this guy that kept
disturbing her for her sister's number
so she told her sister and gave
and the sister gave her the impression
to give out the number
so fast forward three weeks later and my
girlfriend's sister has been on a few
dates
and they're on the verge of being a
thing
so her sister gets a call from a random
girl
and says you should leave my boyfriend
alone
the random girl proceeds to post
pictures of them together
on her on on the guys uh what's up
status
and the caption is we're here forever
with laughing faces afterwards
so my girlfriend's sister was angry at
her because she's the one that
introduced them
when she told me this i was shocked and
confused because she told me her
sister's got three boyfriends and they
all have different purposes one's got
money the other's got good pipe and she
actually likes the last one
swim
uh so i told my girlfriend that assist
sister's a thot
and she got pissed off at me and broke
up with me
am i the [ __ ] for saying something
i said shout out to my nigerian
brotherhood big fan
okay
um you need to give me your backdrop of
that again because there's so many
reasons there's boyfriends right names
so here's
the three fake names so there's
there's mike yeah and his girlfriend
toyah mike and toyah yeah yeah so mike
and tori are a thing yeah
and toy is talking to michael says ah
one guy keeps hassling me from my
sister's number
he's down for my sister i might give
give her the um give him the number let
me just chat to my sister real quick
so toyo goes to chat to a sister and
says yo there's one don called jake jake
keeps bothering me every day he's
feeling you he's feeling you bruv he
wants your number what are you saying
yeah yeah yeah okay baby sisters running
the thing
send him the eleven yes send in the
eleven it's all good yeah yeah oh seven
nine the guy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
she says toy says bet yeah so
um toyota goes to mike says yo sister's
down i'ma give um
jake the number yeah she's all right
cool
three weeks later everything's blessed
toya checks in with his sister how's it
going yeah with my eyes blessed he's
live it's live his life everything's
cool we're going on a few dates a few
nuts everything is blessed all right bet
then she comes in knocking on the door
toya
you'll never guess what
what
look at man status
picture of him and his girl yeah he's
got an ex-girlfriend yeah picture of him
and his girl and the state says we're
here forever yeah okay
and and he says rah what's this yeah she
says this [ __ ] just called me said
leave him alone leave my cologne you
never told me mike had a boyfriend so i
was like i didn't know this guy had a
boyfriend i don't know him he jake you
mean jake jake sorry
a girlfriend sorry i didn't know what
he's got yeah i don't know what he's got
he just asked me for you know he just
asked for the digits brother you said
yeah i'm just the middleman here yeah
allow me she's all right whatever man so
they fall out and toys [ __ ] say why she
vex at me for yeah and then mike sits
back and says listen i can't sit back
and hand up they said yeah
my girl's got three men
all that are doing different things and
she's out kicking fuss at you
because
such as got her
her fourth man has got a girlfriend yeah
and she's vex at you
for this um
your girl's a thought what's she talking
about why is she fixed yeah okay i'm
with you now yeah yeah so he's talking
to you my girl my sister's a what yeah
okay
my sister's a what
she got three men on the go she's vex
about number four this is unavailable
yeah and she's she where's where's this
entire woman coming from she's a scare
shuts her mouth
i'm here for you i'm not gonna have
anyone i don't care who's i don't know
whose blood is what this is me and you
babes i write for you and soy says wow
my sister you know you think you can
come up in my yard and call my sister a
scare get out
man says what
just get out
get out yeah
you heard me get out
what are you even doing here get out
talking about it this isn't us this is
me and her yeah
get out
so man hit up the sng says fellas
great reenactment i see it now yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah without names it's so
hard when he's oh is she boys
um no he's not the one no he's not the
[ __ ] he's not the artist he was
writing for his girl yeah and then the
girl has been a [ __ ] he was in the
family's corner yeah he was trying to
trying to speak the truth trying to
speak real
the sister
is a hypocrite it looks like a hypocrite
and a thought she is a thought yeah
own it toya on that hand's deluded
obviously little sister she's family so
she's trying to protect her she doesn't
want her to be called anything but toya
must know that little sister sofia is a
scare she is escaped sofia the sketch
she is a scare she just doesn't want to
tell her that she's a sketcher yeah she
wants she doesn't want to believe that
she's she's in denial she's playing koi
she's being dumb brother she has been
she's a sketch shut up i think it's an
open and short case there's no
discussion about it yeah yeah you're in
the right miji toya's in the wrong sofia
is clearly in the wrong
and it just is what is his karma really
choose what is bro it is kind of thing's
done
sorry
sorry yeah you got one's gotta go oh
yeah i forgot about that i actually do
make it quick
so to wrap up the episode guys um one's
gotta go this one is a mix it's a mix of
tv and uh people
so
one's gotta go that 70s show
saved by the bell sister sister fresh
prince of bella
same annabelle
why i never [ __ ] her saved by the bell
ever i thought it was okay okay but it
was never like a thing for me okay yeah
yeah yeah they're never like a thing for
me it's just it was whack
say a bodybuilder's trash okay yeah yeah
all right matilda jumanji home alone mrs
doubtfire
matilda
jumanji home alone
mrs doubtfire obviously like the old
school jumanji yeah yeah yeah you know
what this is actually controversial as
hell
i don't [ __ ] with home alone that much
i don't [ __ ] with home alone that much
it's kind of [ __ ]
it's a staple christmas movie g it's a
homemade one and two
classics classics i know they're
classics bro but all of those are
classics this is doubtfire's legit till
now and i know but like so is home alone
bro i watched him alone last year
nah bro
home alone is like
it's cool and that
does it not when you watch it when was
the last time i do not smile when i
watch that film
i just watch it straight face when was
the last time you watched it i don't
know man three four years ago
bro it's staple man i know
i know why it's staple i know it's a
classic bro but i'm telling you i don't
smile on anything it doesn't bring me
any joy all right
i'll just watch it because it's okay
okay let's move on
i say no more say no more all right
um this is in terms of their filmography
yeah so steve carell jim carrey seth
rogen jonah hill
oh
i'll say them again steve carell jim
carrey
seth rogen jonah hill
damn
controversial again if it wasn't for the
office i would say steve carell
because evan almighty was [ __ ] i can't
remember it [ __ ]
was he in heaven almighty he's evan
steve carell was heaven oh [ __ ] yeah
never know mike yeah completely um
trash
um
and max juice was jim though
bruce almighty was jim carrey jim carrey
is a legend
um i'm actually going to say seth rogen
okay
because of the lineup better he's a
better writer
than he is in it just in that lineup i
think seth rogen's great yeah and he
does really good writing and directing
but in just in terms of movies he's in
as an actor he doesn't stand up to
definitely not jim carrey yeah
definitely not jonah hill's journey
jonah hill's a mad man jeremy hill's
onstar he's got um what's the word he's
got diversity yeah he's got diversity of
the range yeah right
and the same steve carrell steve carell
are and seth rogen are like that to me
but the office the office it just bumps
him yeah the office is great yeah office
is amazing so yeah um okay drew hill
112
boys to men
new edition
i can't even think of a drew hill song
um i think i've got a drew hills song in
my is that um is drew hill the one who's
like um somebody's sleeping in my bed
i've got that song on my phone as well
right here yeah yeah yeah
uh 112. that peaches and cream
oh what 112th song have i got in um
um
oh one twelve song was i forgot um
what is this number [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um what's the last one new edition new
edition
new addition bangs as well can you stand
the rain
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bobby brown times yeah old school
bobby brown wow
i'm actually gonna have to say drew hill
okay i'm surprised well if i didn't know
who you'd pick but i'm just surprised
and this is you this will make sense
anyway so heath ledger uh jaquin phoenix
uh jared leto and mark hamill markham
was the voice actor for the joker so all
of these are obviously related to the
joker
say them again heath ledger uh jack
queen phoenix jared leto and mark hamill
geraldo
yeah man in comparison yeah he's a big
ting bro he's not up in there he is
because he was only suicide squad right
yeah suicide squad i think he's in the
snyder cup of justice league as well
i've heard i've heard i've not seen that
movie yeah but he's begging it bro he's
not up there yet
he's not up there yet he was vex
apparently he i'm pretty sore pretty
sure he sued
when joaquin phoenix got joker
really he sued because he had a contract
to be
joking
or whatever and then when they were
working phoenix he was kicking off bro
oh really justifiably but hey
you couldn't bring he hasn't got that
kind of smoke bro what phoenix brought
to that movie was different yeah yeah he
played it
well yeah
could you not watch that movie and think
all right man yeah yeah yeah yeah i
can't do that i couldn't do that yeah i
couldn't bring that kind of smoke so it
is what it is bro i'll take yeah you
have to burn that out all right so your
ones i've got to go saved by the bell
home alone seth rogen drew hill and
jared little there you go one okay all
right good episode guys
catch you in a little bit next week
bless blessings peace
[Music]